if you're going to tell the story of a
metal drummer who's losing his hearing
how do you dramatize that and connect
the audience with the character's
experience
one of the beautiful things about film
is that as a medium that combines both
sound and picture it's actually possible
to modify the sound the audience is
hearing
so that it mimics the perspective of
someone with hearing loss
for director darius martyr and
supervising sound editor nicholas becker
these representations of ruben's hearing
loss were based on extensive research
into how hearing loss sounds that
started a year before any other crew
were brought onto the film
this video is sponsored by nordpass
creating the soundscape of deafness is
extremely nuanced
but there are a few simple techniques
that are used to great effect
in the film this is alex knickerbocker
and chances are you've probably heard
his work at some point watching tv or in
a theater i've learned a lot about film
sound from his channel and so i reached
out to see if he would help me
understand the artistry that went into
the sound of the sound of metal
the two biggest factors in how we
perceive sound are frequency
and amplitude in moments representing
the beginning of ruben's hearing loss
things don't just sound quieter but are
duller and muffled
as we start losing our hearing we're not
just losing all frequencies at the same
rate it's not like turning a volume knob
down we're actually losing each
individual frequency differently
most of what reuben can still hear are
lower end frequencies and so these
frequencies are what we get to hear as
the audience when we're in his
perspective
some of the work to create this effect
can be done in post-production
you can mimic that simply by recording
your voice into a normal microphone and
rolling off all the high frequencies
until
only those lower frequencies are left
for example i could use an equalizer on
my voice to cut out the high end and
make it sound more muffled like you're
hearing now
but creating this effect as accurately
and richly as possible starts even in
how you approach recording the sound
there's a type of microphone called a
contact mic and it picks up
sound not through the air as a normal
microphone would
but through vibrations in solid objects
so the microphone needs to be in direct
contact with whatever object it's going
to record sound through
so what you end up with is a very
different perception of sound
because you're not hearing it travel
through air as normal it's coming
through very condensed
solid matter for example in this scene a
contact mic placed directly on the slide
would have a very different perception
of the sound of reuben
drumming than a typical microphone would
[Music]
this difference in perception that can
be captured with a contact mic
was an important piece of illustrating
rubin's experience of hearing loss for
the audience
[Music]
for nicholas becker sometimes even the
existing recording equipment wasn't
enough
i was able to build a small microphone
that you can put in your mouth without
it being broken
we were able to really recall all the
inner sounds from riz
racing heartbeats blood pressure tendons
moves muscle and bone movements
but creating a compelling sound
experience for the audience and telling
the film's story wasn't just about being
able to create an accurate
representation of reuben's subjective
perspective
one of the most important elements is
how the film uses the movement between
sonic perspectives
and the contrast between loud and quiet
moments in the film
[Music]
this is ridiculous one of my favorite
sonic choices throughout the entire film
is the use of contrast between
perspectives between
loud versus quiet between delicate
versus intense
with a film titled the sound of metal
you expect that to be
abrasive to some degree you expect it to
be really over the top
the opening sequence of the concert is
just that it's extremely aggressive it's
really intense sound and then
the second you get away from that it
cuts to
a peaceful morning inside of basically a
camper out in the middle of a parking
lot
using that kind of contrast just in
perspective changes
really draws your attention to how loud
something is or how aggressive something
is and then gives you a point of
reference that's
totally separate from what that was just
like so
it guides the audience's attention very
effectively that contrast between the
loud concert
and the quiet environment the next day
makes us more aware of the sound in the
camper and reuben's environment
without drawing too much attention to
the sound design itself
you have all of these little subtle
details of the birds outside
the atmospheres feel just a little bit
more pristine and
even down to the foley or the production
recordings
of the blender going in the morning and
all the little details
of the foley as the characters move
around the trailer itself
it's all this stuff that you wouldn't
ordinarily think of
drawing our attention to these sounds is
important because it increases our
awareness of their absence the next day
as reuben begins to lose his hearing
the same idea can be applied when you're
switching back and forth between
perspectives from
the you know normal perception of of
the world around you it's probably a two
out of ten in terms of his hearing
he can't he's having trouble even
communicating with me versus what it's
like to perceive those same things
without being able to hear them
having that contrast makes the starkness
of silence
that much more intense and that much
more heavy the film spends a lot of time
inside reuben's auditory perspective
at the beginning often tying these
moments to more subjective shots that
places inside reuben's perspective
visually
but as the story moves along more time
is spent
back in the auditory perspective of full
hearing and the film only uses reuben's
auditory perspective
for emphasis but because the film
returns mostly to the perspective of
full hearing
during reuben's stay at the deaf
community
what there are lots of scenes with no
dialogue or music
and because of that the sounds from the
environment and the movements of the
characters take
more of a center stage than they would
in most films
the sound team did a really effective
job with this film in the quiet and
subtle moments because
from a technical perspective once you
start taking away music you take away
a lot of you know over-the-top action
stuff sonically there's not really a
whole lot to hide
behind
so you better make sure that your
production sound is really clean you
don't have any traffic you don't have
anything that isn't going on in picture
to distract
and you have to make sure that all of
the background layers of sounds from
the birds outside
to maybe the creaking of the old house
to the wind coming through you know
maybe a drafty point a window
all of those little details need to be
exactly right one of the hardest
balances to find in those
moments is how loud you play certain
foley movements you know even
the smallest most delicate cloth
movements if you don't hear those to a
degree
a film sounds lifeless and you don't
notice it until it's not
there so during these scenes when you
have a whole group of people
not talking they're just signing to each
other
the foley of cloth movement
the foley of the actual sound of your
hands
you know if you get really close into a
microphone
you can hear that you can hear that
there is some movement to it but
obviously if you
overplay that it's going to sound
unnatural and draw attention to itself
so that balance that they struck
in those scenes had to have been
extremely delicate
ultimately the sound design plays a big
role in the emotional story arc and
ruben's character arc in the film
the contrast we talked about earlier of
the loud distorted sounds of the metal
concert
against both the quieter sounds of the
next day and reuben's hearing loss
sets up a kind of sonic motif that
bookends the story
spoilers for the end of the movie ahead
once rubin gets cochlear implants the
film's interpretation of what this
sounds like
while less pleasant and musical than the
concert music the film opens with
[Music]
bears some striking resemblance
nonetheless
through distortion and compression
everything sounds overwhelming
metallic and grating at both the
beginning and the end of the film
there's a shift from a sound of metal to
quiet
and it's reuben's change in how he
perceives these two shifts
that marks his character's development
the first shift is something lost
and the second through the acceptance
reuben has learned
is something gained huge thank you once
again to alex for his help on this video
he makes some of the best educational
content on youtube about sound
and thank you to my sponsor nordpass for
sponsoring this video
i'm very excited to tell you about
nordpass because i genuinely believe
everyone should be using a password
manager on the internet we've all had to
deal with the headache
that is having to manage our passwords
writing your passwords down or storing
them in your browser is inconvenient
and insecure and using the same easy to
remember passwords over and over again
for multiple websites puts you at a huge
security risk but you can solve both of
these problems at the same time
increase your security and make your
life easier by using
nordpass i've been using a password
manager for years and i would hate to
have to go back to not using one
you can use nor pass for free on one
device but premium is super affordable
it allows you to access your password
securely
on up to six devices it lets you share
passwords like a netflix password with
other people securely and it
automatically checks your passwords
against security breaches to make sure
they're secure
you can get 70 off as a part of the end
of winter sale which is ending very soon
by going to nordpass.com
thomasflight go to nordpass.com
thomasflight or click the link in the
description
to sign up for premium and get 70 off
plus an
extra month for free